I think the greatest gift any composer
can have is having a cool older sister I
had a cool older sister and she had
great taste in music and I would raid
her collection a lot and I was six years
old singing don't you forget about me
but it wasn't until I saw the Little
Mermaid I remember under the sea
starting and feeling this like
out-of-body experience that I was
watching a musical number that took
place at the bottom of the ocean and
there was no gravity involved and it was
a Calypso number so that's the one that
like really made me fall in love with
musical storytelling it wasn't staged so
we didn't really have money for stage
shows it was seeing under the sea in the
heights was the dare to myself that I
could have a life in musical theatre at
all I realized growing up I'd never get
cast in West Side Story
there's so little Latino representation
in the musical theater Canon that unless
I started writing I just couldn't have a
life in this world in this world that I
love so much and so I started writing in
the heights my sophomore year in college
I basically just started writing all the
kinds of music I loved into the score it
was like my first time bringing all of
myself into the musical Valley's writing
I think I was so inspired by by Jonathan
Larson in rent and that's what got me
right in was that he was right he wrote
a contemporary musical but in the
heights is when I stopped trying to
write like him them started trying to
write like me this mix of the hip hop
music that I grew up loving and that's
jay-z and Big Pun and mob deep that you
would see in a pure form later in
Hamilton
along with Juan Ruiz get around say yeah
Cruz Ruben blades is a huge one for me
because even blazing one of those give
have have this magical thing where they
can write do most danceable tunes you've
ever heard and yet if you stop to listen
to the lyrics it's about real [ __ ] and
it's not an accident that my sophomore
year in college sort of coincided with
the first Latin pop boom it was
mainstream white America discovering
Ricky Martin in his leather pants when
the rest of us have known Ricky Martin's
is menudo Marc Anthony's singing in
English when the rest of us have three
Marc Anthony albums already 98 degrees
is singing in Spanish and you're like
[ __ ] going on hip hop has incredibly
powerful storytelling
Latin musics has incredibly powerful
storytelling these why can't we thread
the needle of these on a on a theater
stage the thing about 96,000
is that it's also really informed by
this group I mean called freestyle Love
Supreme at that point I was starting to
really freestyle with my friends on a
stage in front of other people instead
of just like the way most of us do it
stoned in a circle in college give us
words mascots it's too nude nail
clippers damn applause sorry what
JMO where are me I was trying to capture
that energy for the interplay between
Benny and who's Navi and graffiti Pete
so that opening thing it almost like
sort of starts and it doesn't really
doesn't scan nicely it's if I won the
lotto tomorrow well I know what wouldn't
bother door no no spending spree what
rhymes with spending spree entrance fee
what rhymes adventures free friends with
me and I wanted it to feel like it feels
in a freestyle show or when you're
freestyling where you're building the
parachute but you've already fallen out
of the plane and then grabbing the rhyme
your friend said and using it for your
next line and the fun of that which you
know would sort of go was assigning
flows to the characters it's not just
assigning musical themes but if you're
writing hip-hop for musical theater it's
also about assigning flow the way in
which that person uses words in the
world
Bennie's flow is very much based on
Chris Jackson's flow who I knew really
well because we were freestyling
together every night then when I wrote
loose navi I was really thinking about
pun which were these very mathematical
lines you know dead in the middle of
Little Italy little did we know that we
riddled some middleman who didn't do
diddily it's silly when we get into
these crazy hypotheticals you really
wants a Brendan go ahead create a set of
goals where it's not enough to rhyme at
the end of the line you got a rhyme six
six ways till Sunday
Karen Oliva used to say you oh you're
putting your your words in your word
boxes because I would do this because
that's literally how I thought of it
like I'm put I'm slotting each word in
the right place so that the line scans
from beginning to end and then of course
the crescendo of the whole thing which
is then crashing all the themes together
word I dropped knowledge I'm a diamond
in the rough but shine a piece of coal
my shot took me a year to write because
it was not only writing Hamiltons I want
song although it certainly is that who
is also proving my thesis that
Hamilton's intellect is what allows him
to propel
the narrative of the story one of the
ways we set that up is Mulligan and
Lafayette and they are doing pre rocking
hip hop it's um John bones in the place
to be two pints of Sam Adams you know
so having Hamilton come in and again now
it's Big Pun times mm x jz in terms of
how much I'm trying to make it rhyme on
the line and there's references to all
of those in there there's mob deep that
I'm only 19 but my mind is older I'm a
diamond in the rough which is a fun
thing that I turned into a shiny piece
of coal that al e^x and D that's
not--that's Biggie's the N o te RA o so
I'm grabbing from the influences and
paying homage to those influences but
I'm also trying to make it be densest
couplets that I can write so if I
express something in four lines the
challenge became can i express that now
in two lines till you could kick the
tire on any part of the line and it's
unfuckable
I'm literally calling on the ancestors
of this of this flow to say that
Hamilton's the future in this group of
friends in the second verse bird check
what we got
mr. laugh oh yeah hard rock like
Lancelot I think your pants look hot
Lawrence I like you a lot it's not a
black lacquer than the kettle calling
the pot they're all skating their
ambitions and the way we show Hamilton's
brilliance is that he synthesizes each
of them into a couplet so Mulligan is
saying I'm the tailor and I'm spying but
I want to do this Lauren says slavery is
ending slavery is the most important
thing to me Lafayette
I'm anti-monarchy I'm gonna do that and
Hamilton summarizes all of it
you know he says he says Lauren's I like
you a lot I think your pants look hot
Taylor let's hatch a plot blacker than
the cattle call in the pot so it's again
demonstrating Hamilton's brilliance by
him saying I hear what you're saying and
I can flip it and then whoa
is based on the AOL startup dial sound
because I wanted it to feel like his
words are connecting with the world and
the reverberating out into the world and
I associate that with the first time I
signed on into the Internet
[Music]
it's the AOL dial-up octave
[Music]
my god there's just no telling how far
I'll go how far I'll go took a couple of
drafts to get there the first song I
wrote for that moment is actually on the
deluxe edition you can hear my demo of
it it was called more it was mallanna
singing there's got to be more I know
there's more oh I hope there's more and
it was sort of her impatience with the
island and as we continue to develop the
story what felt far more compelling was
there's not someone who's sick of where
they live this is not Belle saying quiet
provincial town and I got to get out of
this town it's I love these people I
love helping them and yet and yet on top
of that every time I space out I'm at
the edge of the ocean staring at it
what's up with that and I still have to
get out what's wrong with me
which I think a lot of us feel about our
hometowns or our families and then the
other secret weapon was I went back to
my childhood bedroom literally said mom
and dad I'm coming to stay the night I
am married with a child my family then I
go I have to go do a sleepover at my
house because I think that helps I'm an
actor before I'm a writer and sitting
where I was my angsty ax stand mighty
Gnaeus unlocks that for me and so that's
that was the other secret weapon was
actually going back to my piano to get
mallanna's feelings
here's what happened
JJ was seeing Hamilton and I was not in
the show that day I was actually out in
the audience taking notes JJ was there
and I was a huge fan of alias and his
mission impossible and all the things
all the JJ things and I knew he was
working on episode seven
so at intermission I introduced myself
to him I said hi I'm Lynne I'm the
writer of the show and so I caught him
at a moment where he was enjoying my
work as a joke I said well if you have
any Cantina music you need writing I'm
here because you know I would never
presume to do what John Williams did
John Williams is John Williams and he
said I do have a container moment and I
went huh it was the ultimate example of
shoot your shot in front of your hero
while you're there and I shot my shot
and he actually had a moment that John
didn't want to work on that was sort of
the new intergalactic bar and the goal
was never to recreate the cantina the
goal was like what is this corner of the
universe sound like it was my pitch to
write it in an existing Star Wars
language so I got out a Huttese
dictionary that I found online and and
wrote some lyrics to that and I pitched
like how about some Huttese reggae and
then we wrote it together and I was
still writing Moana at the time so I was
sort of like cheating on the Disney
Company with itself I didn't tell anyone
when I was working on this because I was
behind deadlines on the lan of tunes but
it was it was really fun and it was it
was a fun way to get to know JK because
we were just sharing this logic file
back and forth adding our sounds when we
could
[Music]
the thing I'm proudest of is from the
moment I started writing in the heights
of the present I've always just tried to
get us on the board when it comes to
being on stage like I just didn't see a
lot of I loved musical theater but I
just didn't see a lot of us I didn't see
a lot of black faces or brown faces and
I you know in the heights was like can
we please be here and to see how often
that show gets produced and how many
Latino actors get their sag card or
their equity card because they're in
productions of in the heights and there
is it and in the heights production
happening somewhere at all times makes
me happy it makes me proud on on
Hamilton to have that to have so many
debuts because the roles now exist but
I'm always just trying to get us on the
board I'm always just trying to get us
in that room
[Music]
the lady goes down feet hit the ground
break and start spinning off round don't
stop cuz we don't stop such as cry you
gonna win a neato